oyez me badat
la mairie
[Musique]
ouais
vous vous sentez plus en sécurité
aujourd'hui qu'il ya encore quelques
années
personnellement j'ai dit tout on est le
pays avec le budget militaire le plus
élevé au monde et dans les aéroports on
a toujours peur des baskets et des slips
explosif
pourquoi on en est là parce que les
soldats sont faits pour recevoir des
ordres et se battre pendant les guerres
mais nous mon ami on n'est pas en guerre
soyons clairs on est gravement en danger
voilà pourquoi triple x on ne soit rien
ce jeu un document pas de bol alors ce
fait au lycée
tout le monde sait tout ce qui bouge pas
mais toi
[Musique]
et vous dites que vous n'êtes pas
center kitsch le truc de dingue
j'étais au festival de coachella quand
les guns n'roses ont fait leur grand
retour mais ça c'est beaucoup plus
simple prends ton temps
je suis un pro du bouche à bouche au cas
où jan aps les rich était une
collaboratrice de gibbs
elle va gérer la logistique de
l'opération un homme de votre calibre a
besoin d'une énorme logistique vous fait
confiance en 510 monte pas parce
qu'au-delà de 115 moi je pourrais pas
vous mettre ko
je rigole c'est pas comme si j'avais un
mode alerte ou autre mais c'est comme
couette
[Musique]
hachoud avec 3 secondes pour obtempérer
2 3 si vous vouliez que je revienne
suffisait de me le demander
un appareil qui contrôle tous les
satellites militaires de la planète est
tombé entre les mains de quatre types
très dense où on a besoin de quelqu'un
capable de bouger comme de se battre
comme m
agissez en patriote
il a plu et de patriote que des rebelles
et des tyrans et vous vous êtes qui moi
je suis triple x je vous présente votre
équipe de soutien tiens voilà le buveur
de red bull j'ai pas envie d'avoir des
tocards pour me couvrir alors qu'est ce
que vous voulez je veux du lourd de
l'extrême est du complètement taré
ça c'est une équipe avec laquelle je
peux bosser c'est parti
ça change on sent bien que vous avez
l'expérience c'est ce qu'aime disent
tout
après la rumeur ces gens là sont de
vrais tueurs
vous l'avez eu aucune idée de ce que
vous allez affronter je sais pas ce que
tu cherches mais je sais comment calmer
alors j'aurai pas de bras au petit dèj
au lit
nous on est prêt à mourir pour que le
monde soit plus ses mots qu est ce que
tu es prêt toi je vis pour ça on dirait
que maintenant on est dans la même
équipe on va s'éclater
je prends bas
quand
oh
c'est pas compliqué exploser le show que
la fille et essayer d'avoir l'air cool
quand vous le faites
qu'est ce que c'est bon de revenir
[Musique]
ils prétendent que le monde est plus sûr
aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'a jamais été dans
l'histoire de notre civilisation
vous vous vous sentez plus en sécurité
en tout cas moi non le monde a changé
la guerre que nous menons actuellement
exige un nouveau genre de soldats
il faut des hommes avec les aptitudes et
la rage nécessaire
pour affronter des menaces que nous
envisageons même pas
il nous faut quelqu'un qui peut plonger
dans une tornade alors
sortir comme s'il ne s'agissait que
d'une vulgaire petit prix si vous
vouliez que je revienne suffisait de me
le demander au clair des fonds cd
mais ayez l'air cool quand vous le
faites
jeux semblent faits m'éclater
des flingues des filles
une domination mondiale
zander quel jeu revient
[Musique]